Most audiences agree that jump scares are
the bane of modern horror movies.
Too many use them as a shortcut to frights,
sacrificing mood and atmosphere for a quick
bang that does nothing but startle.
Like any tool in an artist's arsenal, however,
it all comes down to execution.
A well-placed jump can serve as a satisfying
payoff to slow-burning tension, or it can
rocket you forward into a story with a burst
of thrilling adrenaline.
If you're curious about how an often-misused
trope can be successful, steel your nerves,
because we're about to dive headfirst into
some of the best scares that will make you
jump out of your seat.
What's in the boat?
Jaws invented the summer blockbuster by deftly
blending charming humor, rollicking adventure,
and insightful character moments, all punctuated
by a few well-placed scares.
One of them in particular never fails to make
audiences scream.
Before the movie has even shown us the shark,
Hooper, played by Richard Dreyfuss, takes
a scuba dive to investigate an abandoned fishing
boat.
Just as he reaches out to check a tooth lodged
in the mangled hull, well…
After being unsatisfied with the scare in
test screenings, Spielberg re-shot the scene
in editor Verna Fields' swimming pool at his
own expense.
He was determined to get the timing just right,
and all that effort was worth it.
Jaws still plays on big screens most summers,
and you can reliably watch the crowd ripple
with shock even four decades later.
Raptor in the shed
Nearly 20 years after Jaws, Spielberg unleashed
another adventure blockbuster that combined
action with jump-out-of-your-skin scares:
Jurassic Park.
While most of the park's dino denizens are
deadly in their own right, there's one in
particular that has us terrified of maintenance
sheds all these years later.
Throughout the movie, characters speak of
Velociraptors in hushed tones.
Dr. Grant is clearly horrified to learn they're
being bred in the park, and game warden Robert
Muldoon warns everyone of the danger they
present.
But it isn't until Ellie Sattler, played by
Laura Dern, ventures into a maintenance shed
that we see just why the adult raptors are
so deadly.
"Mr. Hammond, I think we're back in business!"
It's cool if you peed your pants a little,
it's kind of a rite of passage.
Closet corpse
Gore Verbinski's remake of the Japanese movie
Ringu, 2002's The Ring is a quiet, eerie story
with no gore or explicit violence in sight.
It relies on uncanny imagery and unsettling
sounds to create an oppressive atmosphere
of dread.
This makes it all the more startling when
Verbinski does sneak in one big jump where
you least expect it.
In a scene that otherwise lacks any serious
tension, Ruth Embry, portrayed by Lindsay
Frost, recounts the story of finding her daughter's
twisted corpse.
Without warning, Verbinski cuts to ...
"I saw her face."
(When you finally watch R. Kelly's "Trapped in the Closet" in its entirety)
The movie never relies on jump scares afterward,
but the fear that this early shock might be
repeated serves to enhance the tension all
the way to the haunting final frame.
"Don't you understand, Rachel?
She never sleeps."
The thing behind Winkie's
While surrealist auteur David Lynch has long
been recognized as a master of the unsettling
and the uncanny, none of his films would comfortably
fit in the "horror" category.
That's what makes it extra startling when
he does go for moments of all-out terror,
as he does in Mulholland Drive.
Sitting in Winkie's Diner, Dan and Herb, played
by Patrick Fischler and Michael Cooke, respectively,
discuss a nightmare the former had about a
man that he can see through the walls.
"I had a dream about this place."
"Oh boy."
"You see what I mean?"
"OK.
So you had a dream about this place."
What begins as a fairly lighthearted conversation
grows increasingly unnerving as Dan compares
the dream to reality.
The two men walk to the back of the diner,
and, in typical Lynchian fashion, some truly
creepy stuff ensues.
It's a simple enough moment, but highly effective
in capturing the surreal-yet-mundane logic
of a nightmare.
Death from above
Alfred Hitchcock's suspense masterpiece Psycho
laid the foundation for the entire slasher
film genre, but it's mainly remembered for
one particular sequence: the iconic shower
scene.
However, one Psycho scene remains a startling
surprise for newcomers and fans alike.
When private investigator Milton Arbogast,
portrayed by Martin Balsam, enters the Bates
house looking for clues, Hitchcock begins
establishing a tension that's vaguely unsettling,
catching Arbogast glancing at each door and
hallway before he begins slowly and carefully
climbing the stairs.
Suddenly …
Arbogast's stunned tumble down the stairs
was achieved by standing Balsam in front of
a rear-projection falling shot.
The result feels just slightly wrong, enhancing
the feeling that we, too, have just been the
victim of a sneak attack.
The Phantom unmasked
It may be tempting to cite jump scares as
a symptom of Hollywood running out of ideas,
but they're almost as old as movies themselves,
and the good ones still work.
One great example of this trick comes from
Universal's 1925 silent production of The
Phantom of the Opera.
Lon Chaney was the first major icon of horror
films, rising to prominence during the silent
era as "the Man of a Thousand Faces."
He crafted his own make-up effects, and there
was seemingly no end to the amount of discomfort
he was willing to put himself through to spook
his fans.
For Phantom, he devised an elaborate construction
of wires and paint that gave him an alarmingly
skull-like face.
Chaney's creepy mug is first revealed when
Christine, played by Mary Philbin, slowly
works up the courage to pull off his mask.
Stories of viewers fainting in the theater
at the film's premiere quickly became something
of a Hollywood legend.
How much Universal may have played up these
reports in advertising remains difficult to
say, but it's undeniable that the shock remains
effective, even 90 years later.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!